liberalism bit builds the stage on which
fascism performs
that's the lesson of
budapest
i would go further
that's so that's the lesson sure yeah
yo
another one bites the dust the brits
soviets and now america
all in the graveyard of empires together
also kind of a misnomer because the
mongols seem to uh roll through it no
problem or hoof through it maybe that
was the problem is that you can't use uh
wheels in the mountains up there what
are you talking about what are you
talking about
talking about the region of uh
afghanistan what is this cryptic uh vic
are you not familiar with the sobriquet
the graveyard of empires
oh yeah that's right i remember now
because of the whole soviet thing and
like yeah i guess before oh did the did
the did the mongols get stopped there
too no no brits the mongols didn't
that's the point is because everyone
used
wheels
except the mongols right and i guess the
persians probably didn't have too much
trouble there either they used legs
apocryphally alexander the great also
tried to attack the region and failed so
yeah there's a little part in uh in
rambo three where they're sort of
standing on the mountain he's got like
his sherpa guide and they look over and
and he says this is afghanistan she's
anyone who tries to conquer her always
eventually fails and then stella looks
he says you know what i mean and
stallone looks over and goes doesn't
take any [ __ ] from anybody
[Music]
we are the pillpot we are all uh phds or
almost phds you guys should just finish
so then i don't have to add that caveat
all the time well maybe a year or two
we'll see
anyway various disciplines
we discuss theory and philosophy
sometimes applying it to current events
as we are today because
we felt pressured into it everyone's got
to take who pressured us into it
i'm not pointing fingers
[Laughter]
only on the camera
however we don't always agree we're not
what you would call a united front
as is expected when you come from
different disciplines and interests but
we are friends and friendship can cover
a multitude of sins
friendship is an empire in itself
and i think that it's actually quite a
virtue that we don't all agree uh i
think there's a lot of other like
nominally leftist podcasts that uh that
it's probably a bit of an echo chamber
and i think we have some
some well-trodden battle lines that i
think make the conversation
better in my opinion and i get and i
noticed that on the last podcast that i
was on i think on the the youtube
somebody said like i'm so sick of
victor's liberal [ __ ] and i gotta
tell you that warms my heart to see that
there's i love to have an audience that
can disagree with me uh it's great
they're sick of your [ __ ]
yeah
what else i wrote down an intro because
you were asking for this last time i
think it's a good idea i think it's a
good idea i'm glad you're doing it we
upload every friday either here or on
patreon and then there's bonus episodes
and interviews that come out every so
often so how was that that was my that
was the intro i wrote
that's good no i mean i think that's
good i think that uh it's like the
paragraph in the about section on our
website
i think that we should have a version of
that at the beginning of every episode
maybe we can just record it once or
maybe you can record it once on your own
if you want as i said everyone's talking
about it so we are going to talk about
it too everything goes through these new
cycles so
we are joining the opinion factory
because we're not better than anyone
else we're just late because we had to
finish our double header for the last
two weeks
on uh performativity yeah let's see that
how would that go oh yeah you weren't
there for that yeah it went it was uh it
was a stellar you missed a couple things
though i think you would like you missed
performative speech acts or the creation
of reality through language right then
the creation of identity through other
performances
uh we discussed al tuzeir and judith
butler but you also missed analytic
philosophy of language which let's be
honest great no one wants to read except
for analytic philosophers of language
yeah damn
damn
so what are we doing here
well usually we only discuss
current events when there's something
interesting to add to it i don't know
that we have something interesting to
add to it
but
as canadians we almost had a philosopher
king this one time
in uh michael ignatieff who had some
opinions about the afghan
war when it began
um and we're gonna revisit those
opinions
they're horrendous spoiler alert
but they were brought up at the
beginning and the same [ __ ] is today
being trotted out in the washington post
so
they
if you say it often enough and over and
over again then
someone must believe it
yeah and i'm actually like i'm curious
because i haven't actually really been
following the opinion pages of this most
recent uh debacle in afghanistan
but
it's the only thing that i've noticed i
think i i think like i read something
about how on fox news and the right
they're trying to spin it they're trying
to spin the failure as uh
as like be blaming on wokeness basically
that that's the reason why like the
whole thing fell apart so that was like
that just made me laugh but like beyond
that i don't know what the bad takes are
like what are the bad things too many
too many gays in the military probably
well other than that
yeah exactly exactly it's like you know
there wasn't a robust enough manliness
in the in the in the american military
to like to
foster the right kind of values always
the problem anywhere there's a problem
not enough manliness involved
exactly
they're also on the fox news i caught
that they're uh kind of against like
rescuing people you know how there's
like a big evacuation of all their
allies and interpreters and people
who've helped them over the years and
fox is like just because you [ __ ] up
and you have to leave doesn't mean we
should take all these people with us and
just suspend
you know immigration policy right like
what the hell's with that like they're
trying to say we shouldn't take anybody
back
with us i shouldn't get anybody and just
let them all be killed that's also their
position which is always very well
thought out and you know benevolent well
fox news has a lot of respect for the
planning ability of al-qaeda a lot more
than they have for
their own military because unlike the
military al qaeda had a plan a
do 911
b
get the american military to invade and
the coalition to invade afghanistan
c serve as translators interpreters and
guides for that military
and then d 20 years later you can get
into
america once the project ultimately
collapses so al qaeda
was actually thinking ahead here but
what is the right like um what is the
what are the takes these days because i
haven't really like been other than the
stuff that we read which was obviously
like ignatius views from back at the
beginning of the afghan war like what
are the main battle lines have any of
you guys been paying attention to this
like just because it seems like some
people i guess i'm guessing
some of like this must be a minority of
you though because i feel like the right
doesn't believe in uh imperialism
imperialism the way it used to
so like there must be some right-wingers
or like good we left
it's not the right wing that's so much
the problem it's whatever
class of people reads the washington
post and the narrative is something like
who's going to protect afghan women if
we're not going to do it
um who cares about the shias we don't or
if we're not going to protect them
they're going to get hurt or killed or
whatever
so imperialism is good because we need
it to defend human rights and it's our
responsibility to defend human rights is
that like the kind of um
liberal elitist consensus right now that
they should have stayed in afghanistan
okay here's a great here's washington
post i think it was uh three days ago
quote if preventing a terrorist attack
on the united states is our only vital
national interest in afghanistan as
biden said then why should people in
taiwan or cuba or poland think biden
cares anymore about their freedom
dude i don't think anyone in cuba was
ever concerned that the the u.s
president cared about their freedom
that's confusing
yeah i mean that's biden's standing
there saying
the this war in afghanistan was never
about nation-building from it was never
ever about nation-building it was about
rooting out the terrorist elements
um and then i don't know it was about
nation building that was clearly by 2003
for it was clearly about establishing
some sort of
democratic
government there and then there was
their first democratically elected
president not too long afterwards right
i don't know i don't really know the
timeline on all of this but was that
really the goal the goal was i mean i'm
not sure if it was
i mean the goal wasn't
yeah exactly exactly that's that was
like i don't think that it was ever it
wasn't initially but it became that way
it became a way to
i guess justify leaving like the whole
war seemed to be a lot of it was just
like how the [ __ ] do we get out of here
now
because whenever you
do a massive military intervention even
if it's just to
root out terrorism you don't actually
have beef with the afghanistan people or
whoever you're intervening on then it
becomes about well who all the people
you pissed off are gonna have all this
power when you leave
well the rhetoric of empire doesn't
change as spivak said long ago and it's
just as true on
uh washington post today the
rhetoric of empire is always white men
saving brown
or brown women from brown men
yeah the civilizing the uncivilized
bringing democracy to the back wall the
backwoods and the backwaters
yeah that's always the that's always the
rhetoric and and but it didn't it didn't
start that way that's the thing it it
was protecting you know it was it was a
national security issue i guess that's
how a lot of things are framed
well someone needed to pay you know
yeah
blood yeah
the american public would not have
tolerated not going to war after 9 11.
yeah and it isn't
the way that this kind of ends up
working itself out sort of
um
just by by the necessity of the
situation is like there's an initial
justification right which is like this
war on terror and like like retribution
but then
they end up in this place and they make
all kinds of sort of like
rationalizations about
nation building but they're not even but
if you look i think like i read
somewhere that the amount of money that
they actually spent on like improving
the infrastructure was like
kind of indicated that they weren't
really serious about nation building so
they were just kind of there occupying
it
for like strategic for geopolitical
strategic reasons but then there's a
bunch of pressures i feel like so
there's like the geopolitical pressure
but then then you end up unavoidably
being in this kind of like moral dilemma
where like the world's watching and
they're like what are you gonna do
like are you gonna help these people
like and then it's like they're already
there
so then there's it becomes a moral
dilemma which we're seeing unfold now
because they made this decision to just
leave and now people are dying because
of like the way that they left
and like the taliban's gonna take over
again that doesn't mean i mean i don't
think that they should have been there
for this long in the first place it's
arguable
whether they should have even done
anything i mean i'm not an ir specialist
but like maybe there's justification for
like some airstrikes or something
against
bin laden's encampments but like a
full-out occupation i mean i don't know
if i ever had some drone strikes
well drones didn't really exist back
then but um but yes uh like in general
like i just don't know
so like i don't think that they should
have ever been there but now that
they're there it's like they left
and there's like these pressures like
there's the geopolitical pressure
there's like the pressure for like i
don't know so it becomes a very
complicated situation is i guess what
i'm saying with lots of different
um pressures coming from different sides
right and that makes it yeah
here is the best take that i saw from
cnn just going full mask off they're not
saying we need to care about the shias
we need to care about the afghan women
and girls it's the taliban are sitting
on a trillion dollars of minerals in
lithium which are essential to tackling
the climate crisis
so we need to not only stay there
but to mine the share of the country
which i don't know however long that
will take i think it takes like 16 years
to get anything out of a mine
but no they want to war there
indefinitely as the mouthpiece of empire
so that we can prevent global warming or
at least not let china address global
warming which was another one of their
concerns that china is going to move in
and address kind of
no then because lithium you can make
batteries out of it right so they're
like yeah that's right but it takes no
none of the geography of afghanistan
into account it takes none of like no no
multinational companies want to go there
in an ins unstable
uh political environment and lose their
their investment
um it's very hard to move [ __ ] in and
out of the country
needless to say because it's landlocked
and and mountainous
so
anyway mascot good job cnn
they have lots of lithium there and yes
it's crucial in quotation marks to our
fight against climate change just as our
pipeline in canada is is crucial to our
fight against climate change so it's
like they had to perform this like idea
that oh things are under control we're
just going to leave
so like it just was inevitable i mean i
don't know how if i buy that completely
but i think it's kind of interesting
that there was kind of like this sort of
ideological pressure where they had to
perform sort of like oh everything's
good like we're going to leave it's
going to be ordered
but if they had done like the evacuation
first before uh pulling the military out
they would have somehow had to like
admit and be like oh things are actually
terrible
so we have to evacuate everyone now and
then if they admit that then it's like
well why are you leaving then
if everything's terrible so they were
like stuck in this kind of bind i think
is the idea this is probably the reason
that a lot of leftists and
probably most of the liberal party in
canada besides
ignatieff
are against this sort of interventionism
and
i guess it's called empire building in a
sense i mean you
they're there for 20 years it kind of
was an extension of the american empire
in a way it was occupied it was sort of
soft colonized
and most most liberals
in at least this was something divisive
about an act ignatieff
was that
you know he he pandered to george bush
and he pandered to that sort of war
hawkish
ethos
but i think a lot of the
canadian liberals
weren't like that they didn't want to
intervene because that that exactly this
reason it gets you into this really
complicated situation
where
staying
is bad and leaving is bad and there's
nothing you can do
some something [ __ ] up is gonna happen
either way and the only thing you can do
is do your best to
minimize the pain and the suffering and
again like if that's in your interest
right whoever's in control at the time
maybe they won't make the preparations
maybe they'll just [ __ ] pull right
out of there and then
things will go to [ __ ] they shouldn't
have been there in the first place
i just found it funny how these
journalists dimwits recite
every age-old
300 400 year old reason that you need to
colonize someone is like
the natives have no idea what to do with
this gold anyway besides we need it for
our righteous crusade against
france and england and the other
european powers
yeah i think that's a thomas more quote
yeah these natives have no idea how to
work this land we should just
appropriate it and show them how it's
done
so then yeah i mean probably not all of
these journalists agree on this but the
ones that i happened to find in my
research for the episode were
don't listen to the american public
biden because they don't know what
they're talking about we need to stay
and i just wonder what the
incentive is for i'm sorry i'm so so i'm
so surprised that like the mainstream
consensus seems to be that they should
have stayed i actually didn't i'm
actually i didn't do enough
picking up the pulse of the mainstream
media right now i mean i listen to this
political podcast well they don't want
to be embarrassed that's part of it
yeah we don't lose
matt what do you think you're awfully
quiet here and i feel like this was your
your chosen topic at a time
well i was just waiting for that to get
out of the way but i think it's actually
really important to situate this in
relationship to two dates uh because
that really will help give a better
understanding of the kind of
neoconservative impetus behind this
conflict right the first date is 1975.
uh the kind of embarrassment that the
country underwent when it became clear
that the
south vietnamese dream was collapsing
and that the us had lost the vietnam war
this was probably the single biggest
pusher uh in the creation of the
neoconservative movement since a lot of
the early neoconservatives and bush
officials that launched this war
grew up during this time period and felt
precisely that sense of humiliation that
the united states being kicked out of
southeast asia by what amounted to like
a gorilla movement the second date
that's really important to note is 1989
with the fall of the cold war because
what's really interesting about this uh
when you see how neoconservatives react
to it is that they're not actually as
triumphalist as you might expect
you'd figure that well the us's main
enemy is gone capitalism and liberal
capitalism particularly seems to be
ascended everywhere so this should be a
moment of euphoria but actually what
immediately starts to happen is people
become concerned in the conservative
movement that without an enemy what
you're going to find is americans
becoming decadent materialistic
committed to crass uh individualistic
pursuits and not
dedicated uh to the pursuit of grander
historical projects like american empire
for example and they were very very
expressed about this like i have a quote
here from
william crystal uh who's one of the
founding members of the project for the
new american history where it says
american civilians at home preoccupied
with the distribution of tax breaks and
government benefits will not come to the
military support when the going gets
tough weak political leadership and a
poor job educating the citizenry to the
responsibilities of global hegemony
global hegemony is his phrase having
created an increasingly distinct and
alien military culture ask any mechanic
or mess boy on an aircraft carrier why
he's patrolling the seas and he can give
you a more sophisticated explanation of
power projection than 99 of college
graduates so there's real yearning to
find an enemy that the united states
could use to essentially
demonstrate its might to the rest of the
world um and another neocon jonah
goldberg put it even more expressly in
the national review where he basically
he just said
every 10 years or so the united states
need to pick pick up some small crappy
little country and throw it against the
wall just to show the world we mean
business
right
and also to kind of reinvigorate the
population and get them to commit to
these kind of grand historical projects
yeah experiment on whatever
halliburton's been working on
yeah absolutely and i think sometimes
people are tempted to give a materialist
analysis of these kinds of conflicts
and say that well the real reason is
money and certainly that's a huge part
of it you know the pursuit of mineral
wealth lithium
oil trade routes in afghanistan but a
lot of the real impetus for it was i
think actually considerably more
ideological because if you look at the
political right the things that they
were concerned about wasn't monetary
wealth it was the sense that if we do
not have a war somewhere somehow then
what's going to set in is decline
uh and with the client will emerge
rivals to us american military gemini
around the globe and we can't have that
which is why we need something like a
forever war in order to stimulate the
population through terror and through
sacrifice
in order to maintain
american imperial rule uh and what's
really fascinating about this is of
course
many many americans conservatives were
okay with this but you need to find a
way to make that palatable to the
general public
and so what you started to see in the
2000s was the emergence of probably the
most politically correct movement i've
ever seen in my entire life which is
embodied by people like ignatieff which
is an effort to try to make american
empire innocent in some way shape or
form by saying yes we need to stave off
decline yes we need to assert our
hegemony around the globe but it's okay
because we're not really an empire we're
an empire light or a humanitarian empire
or an empire of rights
and this is different than any other
kind of imperial system in the past
because of course we're doing it for the
right reasons
and as any of you many of you have
pointed out the irony of this of course
is every empire throughout history with
the exception of the belgians has at one
point or another claimed that it was
warring with its neighbors and
destroying whole countries for
benevolent reasons because it had a duty
to
export its glory to the rest of the
world
so when we see today a lot of the
american media lining up one after
another to kind of endorse american
imperialism it doesn't shock me at all
there were pathetic cowards in the 2000s
when they all got behind this there were
pathetic cowards in 2008 when they
decided to back off it because the
political correct veneer wasn't really
working anymore and now when in 2021
they're pathetic cowards again uh who
don't have the balls to actually just
sit there and say what this was from the
very beginning
which was an extraordinarily hubristic
effort to try to remake the world not
for the sake of the people living in
that country but for the sake of a
couple of american elites who just can't
live with the idea that their country
won't be the biggest baddest and meanest
on the block
and i should all feel ashamed for our
culpability in this kind of enterprise
and the sad thing is the only people who
are really going to bear any
responsibility aren't the criminals who
deserve to be in jail in the hague
somewhere people like bush rove cheney
uh but the people are investors of war
yeah the people in afghanistan are
really going to be the ones who suffer
so my response to this is [ __ ] them all
okay if there was any justice bush
cheney rove
crystal the whole lot of them uh would
have been in jail from 2001
and they would be
sipping on whatever gunk they feed
people in the prison system rather than
the caviar that they get to dine on
every day or better yet what we can do
now is export them to afghanistan throw
them in the middle of kandahar and see
if they're really the kind of tough guys
that they felt that was so important to
train and discipline the rest of the
american society and to become as
charlie kirk calls him the muscular
class
i know
loads of mess boys who think william
crystal's a dick so [ __ ] that guy
victor i wanted to say because i i gave
you what the the liberal mainstream
media was saying the war was about
um and i actually agree with matt on
this but the the left analysis of this
is that we were there or i guess we yeah
the coalition we were there for the
pipeline
and that the taliban wasn't actually
threatening and for lithium
where not a single mine was built in
those 20 years of occupation so i don't
buy that i do buy it was a bloodlust and
it was
you hit us we have to hit back at
something it doesn't matter whether it's
a state or just an area and then hey we
have a foothold for the thing that we
really wanted which is the country
that's easier to take their [ __ ] that's
because it's already developed as iraq
and i think it was also just convenient
for them to just have like military
outposts there to like be able to
conduct their various operations their
various black projects from there but
like you said earlier
they spent
2.2 trillion dollars i think the number
was
and some around 35 billion of that which
is
a very small percentage i'm not good at
math but that was what was spent on
actual infrastructure which became the
reason that they were saying that they
were there obviously not true no one
believes that
no one should believe it except for
ignatieff
so we read
for this um trying to get our our
canadian theorist
what do you what would we call him i
don't even know what to call him
whatever he was a legitimate
historian our homegrown liberal war hawk
it was a legit terrifying to read
idiots exactly like this guy is why
we've been there for 20 years profoundly
ignorant profoundly self-righteous is a
deadly cocktail so
i learned today he's a member of the
order of canada
[ __ ] that sad
for uh his work as a human rights
scholar
oh yeah
and i should say i initially supported
him for a leader of the liberal party in
part because i like that book the rights
revolution it's not a great book but it
was pretty good uh then i transitioned
away from that when i realized he was
doing things like supporting american
empire
and also what he called the lesser evil
which is basically just again another
politically correct way of saying if we
torture uh then somehow that's
vindicated because we need to do
whatever we need to in order to uphold
american military and western hegemony
uh whereas if they do bad things then
that's an entirely different moral
matter the ends justify the means
so ignatieff is probably not a familiar
name anymore he was he was well read at
this point particularly for this essay
in the book that accompanied it
empire light
we read uh what is it nation building
light
and the long story short is you
shouldn't do nation building light you
should be doing it hard you should be
fully committed
he was a harvard prof also u of t prof
came back and ran for the prime minister
of canada
the worst showing in the liberal party's
recent history got absolutely
obliterated
not just because he's a dumbass there
are other factors but partially because
he's a dumbass
he even lost his own seat which in
canadian elections is kind of the most
embarrassing outcome of an election that
you can have for a party leader he could
turn a phrase but not a vote that's for
sure yeah it's the first time the
liberals were ever in third place i
think uh like maybe ever or for like
maybe at least like over 100 years i'm
not exactly in recent history for sure
yeah jack layton took him down with some
never mind that's too deep keep going
well he came from harvard
back to canada tried to run
but
was apparent to everybody that he had
his head so far up his own ass that he
couldn't tell the two apart anymore so
supposedly the most prestigious school
in the country um
turns into some prickish bromide mill
but matt i have not heard this story
you've met the guy i have to hear this
story okay i met the guy twice uh and he
was a douchebag on both occasions but a
douchebag in a somewhat different way
the first time i met him i was working
as a secretary um for a liberal mp over
the summer which is a pretty good job
actually i got to go to parliament hill
and learn everything
our politics didn't really align but you
know i was 20 and i didn't know any
better at that point uh but i got a
phone call um
and i picked up the phone and i was like
blah blah blah this is the office of you
know the member problem that i worked
for and the guy on the phone was like
matthew do you know who this is and i
was like what he's like matthew this is
michael ignatieff and he just slowly
accentuated the words for effect right
because he clearly thought i was
supposed to be blown away uh by the fact
that he was calling and daining to speak
uh to the plebes right and what bothered
me about this so [ __ ] much is
his party was in the dumps uh at that
point when it came to the polling and i
was like who the [ __ ] are you to be this
arrogant to think you're a celebrity
when you're probably carrying the party
to his worst showing ever and then sure
enough what happened happened uh and he
wound up in the ash heap of canadian
history but i met him a few years later
when he come to osgood hall law school
because i was at a conference uh taking
notes i was getting a pretty good
conference but
somebody asked them a little bit about
his election experience this is when he
was still pretending that he was going
to stay in canada and not immediately go
back to harvard when it was safe to do
so uh and then the central america
central european university
but they asked him he was like well you
know the thing is i never really
realized that
politics isn't like a debate you know
when we were at harvard
if you sat there and you presented your
position people would listen to you and
they would take what you said seriously
and then they would offer a bundle and
i'm just really surprised that that's
not the way it happened when i moved to
this country because they just kept on
attacking me and nobody wanted to listen
what i said and i was like you are a
[ __ ] political scientist and you
didn't realize that real world politics
doesn't operate like a [ __ ] seminar
like are you joking like you could
[ __ ] spend five hours in a [ __ ]
campus club and you'd realize that like
you don't even need to be in [ __ ]
government to know that like just
flabbergasting
like ignorance and then sure enough
after it was safe for him uh he tucked
us to iran and did indeed leave the
country which is ironically exactly what
the conservatives said he was going to
do exactly what she said he was not
going to do and exactly what he ended up
doing
so
i am not very fond of the guy hey that's
your harvard education
well that's that guy you know
you know rereading these articles and
i mean i guess i i was pretty young
in the 9 11 attack i wasn't like
politically switched on i was in my
[ __ ] teens my tweens whatever
but i never realized i'm now remembering
and recalling how much this guy actually
shaped the discourse of in canadian
politics over all of these issues how
much this guy
yeah michael ignatieff i mean shaped the
discourse in canada at least and i'm
sure his cow towing to george bush
probably made him a celebrity in the
states as well which is hence his
harvard [ __ ]
i never realized like now rereading this
i'm reminded like all this stuff i
remember hearing about it in school and
not really understanding it because i
was very young at the time and now i'm
just like wow this guy this guy set the
terms of the debate like he's he's
undeniably i mean he's become irrelevant
quite irrelevant but and he's basically
retreated into his lecture circuiting
and his teaching
but um
yeah he he really set the he really set
the tone on these issues and really
everyone's
perspective on what a liberal should
believe comes from this guy who's
actually like a minority like liberal
interventionists are kind of a minority
position in our country yeah in in at
least in our country i don't know about
the democrats in in the states but in
liberals in canada they're definitely
not interventionists like this guy was
but at the time it seemed like they all
were like this guy
so here's the here's the short version
the kohl's notes
one of our dumbest exports not our
dumbest we all know who that is
but this is the embodiment of state
philosophy supported the afghan or
supported the iraq war
supported torture
supported torture in the defense of
freedom or whatever until abu ghraib
came out then he turned tail on that and
said of course i never would have
supported that
um that's a little bit extreme but
america this is a canadian saying this
which is so [ __ ] weird america has
the responsibility to create a
humanitarian empire quote unquote
through nation building and if necessary
than than military force
so
pretty much everything that i read to
you at the beginning that is still being
said in in weipo and and cnn
wow
yeah i should say also he was taking his
authority until people realized he
didn't know what the [ __ ] he was talking
about and he was wishy-washy on all of
his positions because
our great moral saint uh it turns out is
actually pretty flexible in his opinion
so probably the most ugly example of
this was in the late 2000s when he was
running for leader of the liberal party
uh israel invaded lebanon uh to counter
hezbollah and early in the week he said
i'm not losing any sleep about this
israel has a right to defend itself it's
a sovereign nation state and then he got
some push back and then a week later he
was like no no i'm sorry i misspoke what
happened in hezbol and lebanon is
actually a war crime and israel should
feel really bad about this and people
pointed out you flip-flopped on this
like 100
in the course of one [ __ ] week like
last week you were like i know best i'm
an expert and now you're just like i
[ __ ] i was wrong about that it's
actually a really like horrible thing
what's going on there and you can only
do that so many [ __ ] times before
people realize hey you don't know what
you're talking about and b you're full
of [ __ ] uh and
not knowing what you're talking about
and being full of [ __ ] is a lethal
combination and it's just a toxic thing
that this man was able to influence so
many people over the course of nine
years and we would have all been better
off if he had just decided to be quiet
and lecture on isaiah berlin which was
probably the only thing he was ever
really adept at
which is why he lost every political
debate he was in for leadership roles
and for well but eric you don't
understand politics is supposed to be
like a seminar right you express your
point and then we evaluate them
socratically and people aren't going to
attack you and they're not going to be
mean that would be really unfair eric
and that would never happen in the real
world the real world is a very gentle
place
it's like habermas is deliberative
democracy it's a seminar
exactly
yeah no um can i just say i'm glad we're
all together here [ __ ] on liberals
together for once
yeah well i was gonna get to that and
say that like um you know liberals need
not actually support this
philosophical liberals but there's a
distinction between philosophical
liberals the liberal party of canada and
then like this kind of like broader like
like pejorative term liberal but um but
what i want to say is lib
are these actual like opinion pieces
like supporters of interventionism like
i i find that hard to believe like i
would imagine that a lot of people's
arguments are more like kind of
pragmatic it's like we're already in
there like what's actually pragmatically
like the best thing to do and it's like
maybe like i'm not i actually disagree
with that view but but i think but i
guess like what i'm trying to get at is
i don't like do you think that
interventionism like i feel like it's
never been less popular like i feel like
no one seriously actually believes in
interventionism anymore like like i
don't think so like like i think those
opinion pieces that we're reading are
more like people being pragmatic and
they're like well we're already in there
so like what like what should we do
we're in there
like like what's gonna actually like a
minute that's good to point out because
this was written in uh july
whereas the war started in what october
so this is only a few months after and i
guess they probably started asking the
question then why are we here like we
already overthrew the taliban and he
gave them a reason to stay
yeah exactly well this is part of the
problem though because a lot of the
neocons again were
deeply inspired um by american failure
in vietnam figuring they could do better
and then 1989 which they saw is kind of
proof of the legitimacy of the liberal
capitalist order but if you look at the
history of interventionism uh
as a kind of technique uh to try to
constrain various forms of state
domination and state tyranny it's not
typically very effective usually the
paradigm cases that people point to as
well we intervened in the second world
war if you want to call that an
intervention uh and we stopped germany
from killing more people and we stopped
imperial japan from killing more people
but one of the things that's very rarely
acknowledged is that
not only were both of those powers
completely eradicated by the end of that
conflict but they are still american
soldiers in japan and in germany right
now
and the country poured billions of
dollars in aid which is a tremendous sum
at the time to basically reconstruct the
countries from the ground up and then
engage in this very concerted effort
both to democratize japan and to
denazify uh this was later on as it was
called germany no comparable effort was
made during any of these interventions
either in iraq or afghanistan because
the reality was of course they're not
western nations and we don't need them
to actually help us fight against the
soviet union uh so almost immediately
after the afghan war began it was
subcontrarted out to a bunch of brutal
mercenaries who had no loyalty in the
population or the northern alliance
which was a motley collection of
anti-taliban fighters who controlled 10
of the country prior to the invasion
and
they started withdrawing troops
resources all kinds of equipment and
basically decided to subcontract out the
conflict uh to these mercenaries and the
government and you shouldn't be
surprised what's going to happen in
these kinds of instances that everything
falls apart and the reason they did that
is of course bush in his infinite wisdom
decided that it was far more important
to engage in this prestigious conflict
to please his father uh by wiping saddam
hussein off the map and how did that go
right they wiped saddam hussein off the
map
they tried their best to liquidate all
the infrastructure in iraq and
many many of the members of the bath
party ended up flocking to what later
became the islamic state and hundreds of
thousands of people ended up dying in
the region because one american
president was too stupid to actually
recognize he had no business being there
in the first place even if he'd stabbed
his did call him a loser at one point in
his lifetime he should have just sat
there and realized that he is a [ __ ]
loser and this is the best he's ever
able to do
so
it's a real travesty what's happened uh
because if they were going to intervene
and we were going to try to nation build
then we should have recognized that hey
this is the wrong thing to do but b if
you're going to do it is going to be a
hugely intensive extraordinarily
expensive long-term project that's
probably going to take decades longer
than any of our lifetimes if you want to
look back to the
japanese or german presidents right
and
the american circa 2010 wanted sorry
2000 wanted to have it both ways where
they wanted to nation bill but they want
to do it on the cheap at low cost and
with minimal effort and again the only
people who ended up suffering primarily
because of this were the poor people in
the american military who i feel
genuinely very bad to and coalition
military because i have no problem with
the grunts on the ground and the people
of afghanistan and iraq and the broad
middle east uh all of whom have every
reason to be outraged at what's happened
to their country and why such stupid
people uh and that such stupid people
were allowed so much power to [ __ ]
things up as badly as they did well in a
sign i will say like especially um
actually like american military members
because like a lot of people join the
military in america because like they
just need health care and they need
options right like they need
a way of like fi of getting uh paid to
go to school and it's like they join the
military and then all of a sudden they
have to [ __ ] go to some [ __ ] stupid
war
it's like at least another at least in
other coalition members here like in
canada like
you're not faced if you're a low-income
person you're not faced with that same
pressure that would that would push you
to join the military absolutely and
nothing and then when they're back here
and they're veterans who do the proud
boys and the q anons recruit to go and
[ __ ] up the white house in their
alt-right rallies is the veterans okay
they're not all they come back with this
trauma anyway i don't blame them for
that but i mean what's really
fascinating about this is again how much
it prefaced uh what i now call
post-modern conservatism right i mean
people forget this but in 2004 uh a new
york times reporter had an interview
with karl rove uh and he talked about
how it later became out it was paul rove
uh and rove told him all you people in
the so-called reality-based community
don't realize that we're an empire we
are history's actors and at some point
or another we create our own reality and
you people will just be left to read
about what it is that we've done right
and the kind of astonishing hubris it
takes to envision uh that you have the
power to kind of recreate reality from
the ground up abstracting away from
historical conditions material
conditions the kind of differentiated uh
theologies that exist in the region uh
the kind of person with that kind of
remove from
everyday life should never have been put
in that kind of position of authority in
the first place and what's incredibly
sad about this is there are thousands of
karl roves in every american
administration all of whom have the same
kind of bombastic opinion all of whom
make the same mistakes repeatedly and
all of whom quite frankly deserve to be
in jail
and not even just american i was trying
to stress at the beginning like the
british said every same thing about why
they should be in india
they gave every every similar excuse no
we're doing good and i don't know like i
don't actually have an opinion on that
because i don't know [ __ ] about
geopolitics in that sense
but the arguments are the same and it's
the same trotted out uh you know mantra
i should say that noam chomsky pointed
this out when he was having an argument
with bill buckley about vietnam in the
1970s where buckley is like well but
let's look at like humanitarian reasons
for empire and intervention we can see
plenty of those and chomsky very rightly
pointed out to him that every single
tyrannical empire that has existed
throughout history going back to cain
and abel has somehow felt morally
vindicated in bringing its glory through
violence to the rest of the world the
only exception to this rule as he
pointed out and i think this is probably
true uh were the belgians in the congo
where they didn't even make the pretense
that they were doing anything for moral
reasons king leopold was just we're
invading i want money i'm going to be
the richest person in the entire world
and if millions of
sub-saharan africans need to die to
achieve that then so be it it's worth it
right uh so this hubristic concept that
there can ever be an empire that's
somehow innocent is just so remarkable
uh in its tractability and appeal and so
deadly in its consequences that we
permanently need to immunize ourselves
against it
any way possible because of all the
damage that is caused historically i
would totally prefer this
john haggy line that we are fighting
like a cosmic war against
an entire empire of satan worshipers
then no we're actually doing this for
their benefit but anyway if i can turn
to the article for a second um i think
we've all read it but
did you guys
the whole beginning the whole start of
this article like for
paragraphs upon paragraphs
he gives this long
horny description of this afghan warlord
describing him like
deep set eyes with the cold intensity of
a religious warrior he stands there like
a lion flicking his tail
you know this guy yeah he's using he's
using his like uh journalistic
background or whatever but he feels
cucked he definitely feels cocked in
front of this warlord so he's gonna get
him back by uh
by getting the empire to come
but anyways um half about halfway
through he switches tone and we can see
this in this in this following quotation
effective imperial power requires
controlling the subject's people's sense
of time sorry i [ __ ] that up effective
imperial power requires controlling the
subject people's sense of time
convincing them that they will be ruled
forever
the illusion of permanence was one
secret of the british empire's long
survival empires cannot be maintained
and national interests cannot be secured
over the long term by a people always
looking for the exit
this [ __ ] sounds like homie baba
wrote it like it sounds like a critical
theorist wrote it but he's criticizing
the american military for not
subjugating the afghani mind into
thinking that they're gonna be there
forever and he says that was their
mistake this is why it's empire light as
opposed to empire proper
we didn't control their minds enough and
that's the problem
yeah but i don't think that's a big
surprise i mean again look at william
crystal on the project for the new
american century
he overtly says that the biggest problem
is american civilians are too concerned
with refrigerators and television to
assume the great burden of maintaining
quote global hegemony he doesn't shy
away from this word and i think this is
one of the things that leftists don't
always understand about more
conservative liberals and members of the
conservative tradition which are that
it's just that the smartest amongst them
are far more reflective and cognizant of
what it is that they're trying to do and
how it is that they can go about
achieving their goals then we often give
them credit for think about somebody
like carl schmidt for example
and often it's political conservatives
who are the best students of left-wing
theory precisely because they appreciate
that leftists have a good understanding
of how it is that power operates uh the
difference is they don't want to be
critical of it they want to mobilize
those intellectual and theoretical
resources in order to maintain systems
of hegemony that they think are
beneficial and that will somehow also
eventually be vindicated and appreciated
by the people at the bottom right it's
this very insidious kind of way of
reasoning about things that's proven
very very beneficial uh to conservative
movements throughout history going back
to somebody even like edmund burke or
joseph jamaica who said we need to learn
from the jacobins because if we don't
learn from them and apply the same kind
of techniques they're going to win and
of course we can't have that right
neoconservatives were originally
leftists who eventually said
leftists are going to lead to american
decline so we need to learn from them
while trying to reestablish and re-reify
the project of american empire right
yeah
i think uh i i don't know if i
conservatives are the best students of
leftists
yeah i mean
long long time ago maybe this was true
true yeah it's hard to look at charlie
clerk and say like oh you know
he's going to be an intellectual beacon
who's reading foucault and
operationalizing it for the maintenance
and trumpism yeah
and peterson really have their finger on
the pulse of the left that's for sure
yeah i i i i wanted to ask a question a
sort of like
a prop a bit of a provocation which is
like
like liberalism like
to me
it seems imperialism seems contrary to
philosophical liberalism like like like
to me
it's like this like i i think about like
even if i think about like star trek
like the prime directive right like you
know don't interfere in other cultures
like that like this
i mean not that that's like you know
from philosophical liberalism but i mean
i associate that attitude i mean that
seems like to follow from like kind of
respecting the autonomy of i mean i'm no
like liberal ir theorist but it just
seems to me that like liberty like
imperialism doesn't follow i mean matt i
don't know what do you think no don't
ask him we get to respond i have
definitely heard this idea is that yeah
liberalism and imperialism like liberal
interventionism seems like an oxymoron
right because like how can you be a
liberal if you're also an
interventionist it seems like an
oxymoron at least philosophically and
the and the
and i mean the the way it kind of
rolls out empirically is that liberals
are very good at you know they have been
historically very successful at
at arguing for
the need to spread liberal rights right
the idea of liberal democracy and and
humanism and and universal rights
they've been very
vocal and very successful in bringing
those ideas onto the global stage along
with globalization and saying that this
is a necessity and we need to deal with
nations that need to adopt these rules
and those sorts of things but then once
those rules get
taken on to some degree liberals are
also very notorious for becoming
extremely conservative and not knowing
what to do next once people adopt a
modicum of say universal suffrage
rights to education and health and all
those things once once
those things start to gain ground
liberals then tend to
start to become very conservative not
not actual conservatives but like like
they tend to not want to
you know you know break the mold anymore
like liberalism broke the mold
say in the 19th and early 20th century
and then now that we sort of have these
ideas as our baseline liberalism also
tends to seem very conservative in a lot
of its avenues because
because of just that because those are
ideas that we seem to take for granted
here in the western world
yeah yeah but i think i think well
quickly though um you know i
i do think that uh that like kind of
empirically it's it's unfolded that way
but i think at least philosophically it
doesn't seem to follow although i will
say that there are people who argue that
like liberalism even philosophically
there's like a kind of cultural
imperialist aspect to it and like
actually we have this complaint from the
right from the far right from people
like alexander dugan and russia who
argue that like liberalism because of
its uh like because it's it's like if
you want to engage with the liberal
democratic countries it's like you kind
of have to accept some of their rules
and like like i don't know he'll often
complain about like sort of like like
western cultural liberalism
invading uh like the russian society and
starting to make ideas like gay marriage
and transgender rights uh you know make
them more acceptable it's like he sees
that coming from like a reactionary
perspective as a kind of liberal uh
imperialism that's very different than
the kind of imperialism we're talking
about obviously but i guess like it's
true that i guess as a philosophical
liberal like you might be like well i'm
not going to do business with with this
country or whatever this if there don't
adopt which i guess kind of has a sort
of um effect a sort of imperialistic
effect but it's not overt imperialism um
but uh but yeah but but i mean i agree
with what you said eric though that like
in practice it does seem like people who
like do things under the flag of
liberalism
somehow can like fall into a kind of
imperialism i mean i agree i think that
that's true but i don't think that that
necessarily says anything about the
philosophical just like i would say that
you know just because most socialist or
communist countries have ended in like
genocide i don't think that that
actually says anything about the
philosophy of socialism and communism i
just think that in practice the attempts
have just led to that for various
reasons and i think you could say
something similar about like liberalism
and and and you and and imperialism
i would like to submit that ignatieff
demonstrates in this piece
a consequentialist liberalism which is
saying we might have to do a little bit
of imperialism here and bad things might
happen but it's going to be better in
the long run and most of the article
is pointing out all the problems that he
has with the way that afghanistan is
being run
they're not addressing that there's no
faith in the government
there is no sustained agriculture
because farmers have like minds in their
fields so they can't like uh till the
land the government doesn't have fax
machines
the coalition is relying on warlords to
keep the peace
and all the money is not going to
building infrastructure it's going to
western organizations because
also the the coalition doesn't trust the
the afghani government
so what does that really mean though is
like if we stay there long enough
then we're going to get all the [ __ ]
that liberals desire
but he's
he ignores all the subtext of what it
actually takes to change a country in
that way he wants all this development
he wants the warlords to put down their
guns he wants the tribes to all get
along and he wants the taliban to stop
hiding in caves
but what does that mean why stephen
harper
he also wanted stephen harper to stop
being so mean to him because it
undermines support for the liberal
parties so yeah this isn't a man who has
a very realistic vision of what the real
world is like oh my god exactly what
does that mean in the real world how
easy is it to say
we should take away the warlord's guns
easy but what does that mean as soon as
you ask nicely and they say no and they
will say no
now you're advocating taking away the
warlord's guns by force just gonna guess
that they're not gonna let that happen
peacefully which means in effect killing
a whole bunch of afghani teenagers how's
that gonna fly among your subject
population you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then he
says we need to put non-corrupt people
in power again what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
like you're just gonna find altruistic
democratic-minded educated people
sitting around and install them at every
level of government not expecting them
to act in their self-interest protected
by the police until everyone starts to
what just trust them no one [ __ ]
trusts the police in afghanistan they
would rather have the taliban than the
current police but the dumbest [ __ ] this
guy ever said is that a centralized
government is going to sway people's
loyalties from their cultural and ethnic
groups that are older than the [ __ ]
country is
oh yeah so
yeah all we need to do to solve every
problem of imperialism is just a little
bit more imperialism than to quote
unquote develop
agriculture and industry the way he
proposes so that afghanistan can export
well in every single other case that's
happened that means inviting in foreign
multinationals to again quote unquote
develop which never has local interests
in mind so basically
turn it into a colony with a bunch of
western educated bureaucrats to
negotiate with western countries that's
[ __ ] it okay
this time
by the way i believe in fact i know
that afghanis
want schools hospitals
stability
but do they want to be an extraction
colony i'd bet not and what does ignite
think this time is going to be different
someone's just going to dump a trillion
dollars into afghanistan to get their
mining industry going out of the
goodness of their hearts you [ __ ]
morons kind of globally let's just
forget every other time that exactly
this has already been done and tried oh
yeah absolutely i mean the biggest
problem with both of these imperial
projects afghanistan and iraq
was there was this really tabula rausa
type attitude that the bush
administration initially took towards
both of them where in afghanistan the
northern alliance again controlled 10 of
the country
they basically drove the taliban out
installed the northern alliance and then
karzai uh for several decades had both
this administration had very little
support on the ground and they never
really invested uh the kind of time
money or power that would be necessary
in order to legitimate it in the eyes of
the people and one of the other big
mistakes that they made was precisely as
you pointed out ignoring the tribal
leaders who many of whom came from
families who had been in charge of these
local regions for centuries and just
assuming that we need to build
democratic institutions on the model of
a kind of western uh democratic state in
this country and this will replace this
kind of tribalistic kleptocratic system
uh which is very foolish it was even
worth and worse in iraq where they
initially just dissolved the bath party
sent all uh the officials back home and
then tried to get rid and liquidate the
military and the mentality was well
better to start fresh but then of course
all these personnel from the bass parody
and from the iraqi military decided to
lend their services elsewhere usually to
the same very fundamentalists that we
claim you're going to protect
so this kind of millenarian
blow it up and just rebuild from the
ground up this position was
extraordinarily
poorly thought out right just remarkably
badly thought well he couldn't win an
election in canada i don't think we
should trust him on afghanistan anyway
but
the fact that he had enough confidence
to put this in the new york times
well you know if you've michael daddy
never let not knowing anything about
anything get in the way of just having
something to say about a subject matter
that's what i learned about the guys so
well i i guess it's probably
too little too late to talk about
the kind of critical theory take on on
on war in the 20th and 21st century
but i mean some of the comments earlier
about about this has always been the the
way of empire and and this is
imperialism is you know as old as as
human beings and political gather like
it's
it's not quite true because you know war
has fundamentally changed over the 20th
century right
you know you know even ignatius wrote a
book called virtual war which is about
the ways you know like
most people
me included like i don't get the first
person view of war i get it mediated to
me through
cnn
newspapers
images
in the media right and what war becomes
is something that isn't real right this
is like baudrillard's point about war
it's not
like he he wrote those those papers
right the the gulf war never happened
and it's not that he's saying it's not
real it's that he's saying it was
broadcast live and the event itself was
distributed through the media the event
itself like the the part on the ground
what happened really
was
such a small part of the global
broadcasting of this event through all
the media channels and the curated sort
of live feeds and images we would see
and war today is so much different than
it was
you know it transformed during the cold
war right it completely transformed we
don't major powers don't go to war with
each other because they have nukes
that's just the obvious thing we have
all these sorts of scares nuclear scares
we're not afraid of them anymore for
some reason
but they don't happen right we get into
these proxy wars right
pakistan hates india so they fund the
taliban right and then
america doesn't like what is going on
there so america intervenes because
afghanistan's not a major power they
don't have nukes they were afraid that
iraq did turned out they didn't so
i guess all's well that ends well there
they got saddam but you know the the the
way that war is conducted today is
completely different it's not nation
building right it's not i mean it's not
empire building it's nation nate and
sometimes it's under the banner of
nation building but nobody's expanding
their empires anymore those
conservatives you were talking about
earlier like dugan and yorum those guys
are
concerned with this sort of old
nostalgic view of empires expanding
their borders that doesn't [ __ ]
happen anymore oh i think it does i mean
joram is actually endorsing expansion
okay it does because israel always wants
to conquer palestine
extend its borders resourcing expansion
of the
essentially the russian empire
eurasianism you're right that is such an
old-school [ __ ] way to do it and okay
maybe israel will succeed in
exterminating palestinians and expanding
their borders into this
we can have them both i mean people can
be [ __ ] in many different ways we
can have one kind of empire and then a
second empire on top of it we don't need
to be exclusionary that way
the way most the way we consume images
when has state building ever worked why
don't you go ask honduras and guatemala
how they feel about state building
i think it clearly worked again if you
look at i think the only instances i can
think of of it being relatively
successful again
were in germany and japan
and again that's still an ongoing
project because as pointed out we still
have military personnel there right you
might also be able to argue for south
korea right most people would argue that
those that those cases were successful
because of already a lot of pre-existing
conditions
no exactly they're exceptional cases
right like like it's like you you have
to have like like a baseline of like
um
like i've actually been reading a book
recently demographic culture would be
the first thing that afghanistan does
yeah well that's this is what pisses me
off is this guy [ __ ] uses bosnia as
an example like oh look
they're both muslims why can't they both
learn to get along regardless of the
fact that [ __ ] bosnia is like a 20th
the size of afghanistan yeah i know
exactly and that's where the the weird
thing comes into play as well about the
motivations it's like how do you really
determine what the motivation is is it
ideological i don't know how many times
i've
i've watched uh detective shows and been
like actually he wasn't after the money
it was an ideological murder i don't
think that ever happens and and those
sorts of but we do make those allowances
for the states and the reasons they go
into other countries
it's ideological has nothing to do with
the material benefits or the wealth of
the natural resources it's ideological
okay i've never murdered anybody for
material reasons i only murder people
for ideological reasons all right that's
that's what i believe in not what i want
you know the funny thing is he was asked
years later what did you learn from the
iraq afghanistan debacle and ignatius
response was well i realized that
motivations and intentions matter and
when asked to clarify i said i was
shocked
it was like i was shocked to realize
that sometimes people will say
that they want to do things for a good
reason and it turns out they don't i'm
like wow so you've discovered the
concept of lying
so if you got a harvard degree between
the years of 2000 and 2010 go ask for
your money back
yeah it's like wow you so you've now
understood human duplicity it's amazing
this is a political [ __ ] scientist
yeah
i mean if if he's ever heard of like
what goes on in the discussion under
post-nationalism right we're not we're
not like all these individual nation
states looking to expand our borders we
are a globalized world at war with
itself
right it's if it's an ideological war
then it's an ideological war that's
internal not not with an external enemy
of course we like to have an external
enemy because that's really nice to
justify
and give you know the people something
to hate something to get behind but
really it's war with the self right it's
an internal war a war with terrorism in
afghanistan that's not a war with some
external enemy right nobody's
no afghanistan isn't a newly discovered
land it's a
if anything it's a newly created land
after world war ii
but with
with this war
it comes off like it's
purely i don't know i guess the the
motivation maybe isn't ideological it
maybe it isn't material
it's some kind of it's some kind of
virtual war as both beaudrillard and
[ __ ] ignatieff would say
but the virtuality of the war means that
it's mediated and presented to us in a
certain way and we receive it in that
way we don't know what's really going on
but
we have to we have to sort of infer from
what we're given in the media right like
that's
i guess that's that's the sort of point
right like vietnam was the first
televised war and the gulf war was one
of the first wars that was
also
all these strange images like
gis and we got to see like rocket vision
and like all those weird things that you
would get it was there's a lot of live
footage as well and that's why the war
never happened is because it really just
happened on our television screens
and that the critical perspective builds
from there stay tuned for my next video
anyway we'd be remiss i think we're all
like mostly in agreement but i'd be
remiss if i didn't include his last
paragraph
in this discussion which is just
profoundly racist and colonial
but in a final brilliant moment
it has to be intentional like i can't i
cannot imagine that you would quote
uh rudyard kipling and not mean this but
he says
the nation builders to bet on are those
refugee families piled onto the brightly
painted pakistani trucks moving up the
dusty roads the children perched on
mattresses
like mowgli astride the head of an
elephant gazing towards home a fictional
[ __ ] indian boy created by
mr white man's burden himself
when you're imperializing who gives a
[ __ ] indian afghani whatever they're all
the same but he quoted [ __ ] mr white
man's burden saying these are the people
that i'm betting on
no one with a doctorate is that dumb
i refuse to believe it and if it's
intentional then just [ __ ] off
do you think is it also possible that
just like 2003 or two or whatever this
was just like a much more different time
than we realized oh god
he says he says imperialism used to be
the white man's burden that gave it a
bad reputation but imperialism does not
stop being necessary just because it is
politically incorrect
like i wonder just like the only reason
i'm saying that is not to like excuse it
it's just like it's just like i just
can't imagine how an editor
would have like like today i just don't
think that it would be possible for like
an editor to go through that and be like
yes this is good like like i think that
it's just i don't know it must have been
just more different like than we sound
like something that would get published
under the trump administration oh yeah i
was gonna say the claremont institute
would eat that [ __ ] up oh yeah sure yeah
he's not only i mean the corny for the
afghan warlord he's also really horny
for this jay sock guy that he keeps
talking about like an american with a
floppy hat with wraparound sunglasses
who stands silently in all the rooms and
then orders air strikes like when
necessary
the muscular class without the quote
last quote without the americans in
floppy hats nobody is going to feel safe
enough to start building a house with
bricks
yeah i mean it's not half as bad as the
[ __ ] tucker carlson spews like on a
daily basis but but tucker carlson is
not wrestling with moral issues on the
world stage he's talking to
[ __ ] [ __ ] americans who want to
vote republican
ignatieff was trying to like stage this
sort of moral debate
in the pages of the new york times with
peop which people from other countries
do read i'm not sure
who from other countries watches [ __ ]
fox and friends i do
it's confusing though that like people
like tucker that people
carlson like people like tucker carlson
are all of a sudden like there's a weird
shifting because when trump was
president i mean this we don't have time
to talk about this i guess but
it's just funny how when trump was
president um there was like all this
anti-imperialism on the right and now
like i think tucker carlson and these
others are kind of like having these
uh all of a sudden now they're saying oh
the reason we lot like we lost the war
and we should be ashamed for all this
stuff and wokeness in the military and
but i don't know and then before it was
trump's idea to [ __ ] leave it's just
anyway i think it was obama too
yeah yeah a couple people have asked me
and been very critical of me for not
connecting neoconservatism to what i
call post-modern conservatism so to
those of you who've sent me nasty emails
about this i have detected the exact
moment where the transition takes place
and it's very much in the line that eric
was talking about uh it's in dinesh
d'souza's book the enemy at home the
cultural left and his responsibility for
9 11. okay so what in this book uh this
is his 2007 book so by dinesh d'souza
before he goes to jail uh he says in
faulting the cultural left for 9 11 i am
not making the absurd accusation that
this group blew up the world trade
center and the pentagon i am saying that
the cultural left and its allies in
congress the media hollywood the
nonprofit center and of course the
universities uh are the primary cause of
the volcano of anger towards america
that is erupting from the islamic world
the muslims who carried out the 9 11
attacks were the products of this
visceral rage yeah it was movies that
did it that's a 911 conspiracy theory i
haven't heard that will and grace this
is the tipping point where
neoconservatism transitions to this idea
that the enemy within is the more
important one they really wanted to stop
the avengers from coming out with all
these sequels and it didn't work
unfortunately
the avengers live on and the world trade
center does not and that's that's
that's their failure for not bombing
hollywood
they got the wrong coast i think yeah
it's our fault for not being nearly
horny enough for jay sock
they didn't fly planes at harvard or or
hollywood studios
that was there that was their bad wasn't
that a simpson joke at one point like oh
yale could use an international airport
yeah that would be better
cool
yeah no no lots more i was just going to
say that i mean it feels like a good
place to wind things down here
i feel like i got something got
something out of my system that just
pent up through the course of reading
the article
then [ __ ] mowgli and the json guy in
the concluding if anyone wants to read
it read just the last the last section
i'm actually actually i did i did have
one final question which is just like uh
pills do you see a like continuity
between like this topic i wonder how you
see it relating back to like the that
your your video uh your documentary i
mean certainly reading all that [ __ ] has
made me far more conspiratorially minded
and if it doesn't make sense on the
surface there's probably a reason for it
and if quote unquote freedom is the
reason given by the imperial
ventriloquist dummies at wapo
there's probably something we don't know
so obviously the parallels of imperial
interest are there but we've had the
curtain pulled back a little bit on what
happened in latin america the senate
investigation the leak so we can see
what it's really about who are the real
actors and it was pepsi ford chevron
itt and so on so
i i think there were some assange leaks
either over iraq and afghanistan i
forget now what they said but
for the most part we gotta speculate
about who did have the private meetings
with bush who has his phone number
uh probably defense contractors to start
with but who knows what else and what
what this has taught me is that
everything makes sense
once you have the receipts the text the
private meetings and so on
so there's probably a reason why it
happened like it did and there's
probably a reason that biden's pulling
out now and
unless he the other possibility is he's
just too senile to forget the secret
deals that he's supposed to be upholding
yeah it's really it's really hard for me
to believe that there's no material
motivation behind it with the with pills
video and the access that some of those
companies had to the executive wing
versus there were pipelines in
afghanistan owned by companies i'm
pretty sure chevron
bought out the company that was based in
california that owned a pipeline in
afghanistan
it's hard for me to believe that there
the executive branch was not also
fielding you know calls from these sorts
of people who were saying yeah
afghanistan's a good idea let's go in
there because we can we can we can uh we
can uh build on some interests there i'm
sure that i'm sure there was some of
that motivation i think it's a
combination of different motivations but
i think i think i think matt was right
earlier that there there is there's a
whole confluence of ideological factors
too and i think also politically i mean
in america his for historically wars are
popular they help the president usually
uh look good so there's like a political
motivation as well
like i mean i mean think about think
about margaret thatcher when she invaded
the falkland islands like her [ __ ]
approval ratings were in the toilet and
then all of a sudden the falklands war
came out and it was a gift all of a
sudden she became like the iron lady the
most popular prime minister at the time
one thing that i did look up that i
think i'm going to look up anytime
there's any sort of
interventionist project was foreign
direct investment in 2000 foreign direct
investment in afghanistan was like zero
the second the war happened it shot up
to
like unprecedented levels in afghanistan
forever and then every year you can see
it kind of ticks down as they realize
this is going to be a harder project
that they thought until last year when
it was basically down to zero again
and then and then lithium magically
crept into the modern debate despite
them not having any mining
infrastructure so that's that's also an
interesting thing but
but that's uh we'll we'll see what
happens to biden right this is the
greatest pull out in history so we'll
see where he decides to blow his load
hopefully hopefully he doesn't
impregnate her
i did have a thought maybe he did this
hoping it would end in disaster so that
he wouldn't have to make good on his
promise to pull out of iraq
you think he's you think his people are
smart enough for that i don't think so
i did it by the way in other news
ryerson university just announced that
they're going to change their name after
after reading a report with a few
recommendations yeah with the
recommendations hey oh well that's fun
and there's a couple i'm pretty sure
there's a couple like high schools and
[ __ ] in toronto also named after ryerson
but i guess that's uh that's stage two
is ryerson a problematic person
well b.i he was helped he like
influenced the residential schools but
also like was also a big influence
around like the universal schooling in
canada so he was a complicated figure
but definitely helped the residential
schools
all right well thank you all for
listening we hope we did a a bit of the
theory job it's kind of easy looking
back in hindsight and picking up
what an idiot this guy was but he seems
like kind of an idiot even by the
standards of the time yeah and we all
agreed even the libs who also just want
to say obviously that you know ignacio
is not really a lib uh he's just like a
neolib we lost our true lib and jack
layton
all right thanks guys see ya
[Music]
you